good afternoon everyone uh it's been i'm
sure a long and
very technical conference here
and
this talk is going to be a little bit
different in the sense that what i'd
like to talk to you about are some very
basic really fundamental principles of
information visualization
design the kind of challenges that we
face in this discipline every day and a
few practical little winning ways that i
have found that helped me along to make
information tell stories about numbers
that people actually want to believe
so my name is mark gundland and as you
can see i do a lot of things
things in life
basically i am a freelance consultant
and i help my clients bring innovation
to market turn good ideas into great
businesses and along the
path i've worked as a product manager as
a software designer and lately i've been
doing a lot of consulting around
data science helping people
see
the meaning the inside the power of the
numbers they store on their hard drives
so
today i'm going to talk about just one
of the things that i do in life life and
that is information visualization
and this is really a good place to start
because information visualizat in
information and visualization has been
around with us for a long time
time
i would argue that it is as old as art
in fact some of the very first art we
made was a scatter plot
now the remarkable thing thing is that
to this day we still don't know what it
means because the people who made it
didn't yet know how to write
well things have changed
we're no longer putting marks on cave
walls we're posting on facebook walls
but the same challenges of getting a
message across
a message that is going to stand the
test of time they
still apply
now
it
remarkable now here's a remarkable story
and it happened right here in london and
it is the reason why some of you are
alive today
today and this is this seemingly
insignificant plot
started the modern science of
epidemiology there was a cholera
outbreak and a fellow called jon snow
was was seeing people die around soho
now cholera rabbaq then was
a real killer
just as it is in developing countries
trees right now and what he knew that
these deaths were clustered in a certain
area and he traced this back
to a water pump that was dumped that
that was built over a cesspool
now what he needed to do
was
to convince the authorities to build
sewers underground rather than
overground and being able to
to not just relate the anecdotal
evidence but to actually with each mark
show where the deaths are help them to
connect
disease to its cause
because and in fact the pump you can
still find i think at broadway street
today
now
now if
in the past visualization has changed
the way we see the world it is becoming
ever more ever more critical who here is
seeing this graph for the first time a
show of hands
well
this
is the famous hockey stick graph which
is arguably the most controversial and
the most important chart in science
literally our future depends on how we
read how and interpret this graph enough
to create
policy change
change and the remarkable thing is is
what an ordinary graph it is
when
so much has been written about it and
its consequences whether that
information is true or not and this is
really what happens when scientists make
their
own
visualizations with without really
regard to the fact that they're going to
be seen on tv
and
and and really in science we are so used
to being objective but in a sense
that's never as objective whoa hold on
never as objective as we think for
example
how we present
two
incomparable axes
the change in temperature on the y-axis
and years on the x-axis
says how do we scale that presentation
can tell completely different stories
for example
paul
if if you make this graph
like a long time series all of a sudden
what's happening at the end doesn't seem
so dramatic
of course
of course that goes the other way around
the other way around
so what do we do
well visualization design makes
decisions that's what designers do
and the decisions we make necessarily
affect which interpretations of the data
are facilitated and which are impeded
we are creating subconscious impressions
in the minds of our viewers words and
those impressions can be manipulated
they are
they can be of course made honestly
legally as well but mostly they need to
be communicated as you see al gore is
trying to do
so
imagine you are making
the most important graph in the world
let me ask a simple question is how do
you decide what is aspect ratio
should be you see the dramatic effect
it can make on how people judge the data
at a glance so what should the aspect
ratio of a graph should be like i said
i'm here to address some very basic
questions so please please
should it be one-to-one
one it's fair and square as show of
hands who thinks it should be one to one
okay no one thinks that well very well
what about sort of
more like what they did which is you
know three to two
it's wider than it is taller it's a
little bit like a landscape okay
photo print is that the right answer
anybody anybody wishes to raise their
hand
okay
no one no tankers here okay well next
option so how about we take the golden
ratio after all it's it's like the way
nature arranges uh seeds in a sunflower
leonardo da vinci drew it in his
notebook so it must be
beautiful pleasing in the right anybody
wishes to take the golden ratio as the
aspect as with the aspect ratio of the
most important graph in the world
a couple of hands went up well there we
go so we have a default option but let's
see what else we can we can do we can
ask
a
perceptual psychologist
and they will tell you that we
are
pretty bad at making judgments of
of deviations from the horizontal and
deviations from the vertical but we're
pretty good at judging deviations from
the diagonal so the idea is to bank
the
is to adjust the aspect ratio so we bank
at 45 degrees because it is perceptually
optimal for orientation discrimination
who thinks that's the right way to make
to choose the aspect ratio of the most
important graph in the world any hands
no we oh one person trust trusts uh
uh psychophysics amazing
um well next of course we could ask the
mathematicians now the mathematicians
believe that aesthetics is an
optimization problem
so of course what are we going to do
we're going to minimize arc length by
keeping area under the plot constant
ah that's that's clever because that
that means that we get the shortest line
showing the change in climate
is that right
is the mathematic is a mathematical
criteria right any hands any takers
wow no one
no one trusts mathematicians
amazing you you a few people will take
the word of a psychologist no one to
will trust mathematicians what a life
okay so we're all software developers
here me too by the way um let's just
take the screen size or the window sizes
given after all an iphone can't be wrong
wrong and besides it's it fits so
obviously that must be what the user
wants
anybody believes that this is the right
way to
to decide on the aspect ratio of the
most important graph in the world one
person does how many of you
when creating being a visualization has
actually used this heuristic i wonder
and finally
you could ask a graphic designer the
people who really you know make their
living telling stories and they'll say
you ask them what should an aspect ratio
be and they'll say it depends
well what does it depend on
it depends
on what is the story the user is meant
to believe
now you see how how two books can get
can easily get written about a simple
chart when you you start taking that
kind of a
attitude towards being honest credible
faithful to your data who by the way
thinks that's a good idea
i look one person in the room
well
very well what about about all of you
who didn't raise their hand
how how do you how do you think we can
decide
to choose the subconscious impression
that the most important chart in the
world is going to make
well
the amazing thing is that information
visualization is such a young science
that
we don't really have
answers that everyone believes it just
depends where you're coming from
it does indeed
now
if you think
think that that this this problem
is somehow isolated let me let's let's
take another very
very very important uh applications and
that's google maps
now
we are living on a sphere floating for
space
and the trouble with spheres floating
through space is that when you try to
put them flat on a table you'll wind up
ripping their surface apart you see
there is no way to represent the earth
on a map that doesn't distort this
directions angles shapes or areas
so we have to make a choice just like
with the aspect ratio and just like with
the aspect ratio that choice is very
important
now google in their in their infinite
wisdom of course it's google they must
be right choose chose the
merc
mercator projection which was originally
designed by the way for
ship navigation because it preserves
angles not areas and
a lot of peop people in the world are
not pleased with that
now the problem
you have is is almost is in a sense
political because
we make judgments based on what our
where charts are saying for example on
this chart it looks like africa is about
the size of the united states
states maybe a little bigger but
certainly not the size of united states
china india and just about all of europe
put together with with peru thrown in
for good measure
now think about it this is the map of
the world that our children
are growing up with
this is their sense of how big we are in
pro in proportion with the rest of the
world none of us get to see
and
that
and of course
we can understand here in this room that
this is just
a
a a projection of three-dimensional
space on onto a two-dimensional plane
but that's not what ordinary people
think
thing and it is by setting up their
subconscious bias to what kind of world
they're living in that the choices
as
as people as people who design
information visualization really make a
difference so
you know we can actually quantify this
distortion using a t so
so
indicate tricks and that is very simple
just at every point on the sphere you
place a little
circle and then you see how your
projection distorts the circles onto the
onto the map map turning them into
ellipses and of course you see right
it's obvious because the mercator
projection is biased towards the
northern hemisphere where which has
has a lot of land mass and where a lot
of
where
were
rich people tend to live versus the
equator where most of the poor people
live of course there are better choices
that we can make like the robinson
projection which actually i would
suggest you use when you wish to depict
a visual
visualization on a global scale
however
that's not
the only choice we have you see because
if distortion is inherent
then let's admit to it so cartograms
distort the size and shape
of regions
in order to make their area proportional
to the variable of interest so this is
what they look like if if what we're
interested
is the geography of land mass
but is that really so relevant and so
interesting anymore after all you know
we don't nav navigate our own ships we
fly by airplane there are some much more
important variables i think in the world
than land mass
population and wealth
seem to be
what
drives
drives our economy and our everyday life
and and i just wonder what would it be
like if along the side along
the
the map of the world we know so well in
our geography classes our children would
grow up with maps like this maps that
really
show
how wealth is distributed and how africa
vanishes of the face of the earth
we
i
and and this is and this is the
essential point the way we visualize
sets
up
our audience for the kind of
interpretations
that they are going to make
right you showed it to me and now i i
see it for myself that's what this is
all about
so what do we have to work with
if we want to express numeric values
that have absolute magnitudes
the trouble is that
the ordinary human brain doesn't think
like a mathematician
a visual perception only makes relative
judgments
so what do we have to work with we've
got position which which by the way can
be seen relatively accurately but
afterwards things sort of go downhill so
we got position
shape length orientation area and volume
hue saturation brightness texture
transparency alignment proximity
containment connection labels we've got
glyphs we can put in motion and flicker
and if we get permission electric shocks
i don't know what else
wow so much choices
the
the challenge of information design is
how do we make those choices in a way
that
does not
mislead our viewer well let's see just
how easy that is to
do do um
here's a little puzzle
which which of which is bigger and by
how much
so who here thinks
the square is biggest show of hands
one one person yeah yeah okay good good
good good two people
okay
who here thinks that one one of the long
rectangles
is bigger anybody
ah
three four five something like that okay
what about the fat rectangle is he the
big guy
haha one person there what about the
rest of you uh
you think
do you think they're cool things are all
the same
no
[ __ ]
now
there is only one problem here
this is exactly the tool
we give
financial traders
to
get an overview of the market
and
you know that's my
after all their jobs aren't supposed to
be easy they get paid for something
okay well let's let's let's let's see
how let's let's see just how this
how this all works um
so
who here
thinks that just please bear with me
this is important who here thinks that
these two circles are the same
same size please
believe in the authority of your own
senses not what other people
seem to think you are the best authority
to make this judgement who here thinks
they're the same size
who here thinks they're different
really
can you would you like to explain
i just went for the second option
okay
now
who here
still thinks they're the same
size now who here
who here
based on the authority of your own eyes
the one incontrovertible truth you have
that dwells within you
who here believes those circles are the
same size
well what does same size mean does it
mean what is drawn
or what is seen
you see because
that question is disconcerting why
because what you see here is a bubble
chart
and a bubble chart is the way we
we figure out that uk government
spending makes no sense
i know these guys are just blowing soap
bubbles out there you know and they're
amazing
the guardian did a good job here in the
sense they labeled the bloody bubbles
okay
but
the perception of size happens
far quicker than you can read
a label written
in white on gray
and that has a problem because by the
time
you've read the label your
mind has already made
a judgment a preconception a bias about
its magnitude and that's the kind of
challenge that we as information
designers have when we actually want to
be understood
now
his and his an an interesting
situation
uh when that happens every day actually
um
who here
which is brighter
there are the rectangle on the left or
the one on the right
in the first one here
left
what about in the second one
what about in this deferred
now the problem let me see
is that
your
visual cortex
wasn't
evolved to read graphs
it was evolved to hunt monkeys and birds
in the rain forest
where being able to draw distinction in
shadow and light
meant the difference between
starving and hat and not having children
or being the king of the feast and
that has certain implications
this is
well this is actually what's going on
now
think about it this is on the brightness
channel one of the very best channels we
have for communication
where in fact what we are communicating
is not
the
the element
but is its surroundings
and this happens of course in real life
when we're trying to color color
color in our maps
a a
a region of blue surrounded by
by red
is seen different than the same region
of blue surrounded by blue that's just a
fact of life and if you don't like it
you do something else
oh damn it we're back to the previous
problem
well what are we gonna do we're gonna
call him the guardian
now the guardian here here
begins to present
a real solution in the sense in the
sense that they
label things
and they add callouts which convey the
story and they give different
perspectives on the data
they have only four gradations which are
easier to read than a continuum
clever guys at the guardian but not
everybody's got that kind of budget i
don't
so um
for my sins i get to analyze the
performance of online advertising
campaigns it's actually fun in a
perverse kind of way um
but so this is so here we are looking at
comparing impressions to to clicks over
content in various categories and if i
just left it at that
i don't think that the client would
really get the picture because it's not
so easy to read
but we add things in we turn a bar
bar chart into a traffic light bar chart
chart the first thing we do is we put
which i did was put labels
labels
both of the categories right next to the
numeric labels rather than putting let's
say numeric labels at the end so it's
easier to read and then just make it
really easy i find that the more
the more the more people are paid the
harder it is for them to read the graph
this is this is just my experience so so
now everybody sort of
knows about traffic lights so that's how
we color our bars
bars and then we use use the the light
the the traffic light to show which
whether
whether a given content category is
green meaning good to run a campaign on
okay
but
let's see how
now
now one of the things we we want to do
in visualization is to work with color
and color is tricky
and this is just one of its many tricks
um
who who here has ever used like a
rainbow palette
like it's a rainbow color map
well
they suck
for some things
um
here here just some of the things that
go wrong with them first of all hue
order is not obvious does green come
before yellow or yellow before green
is is that
immediately obvious
i don't know but there's something worse
you see we
we perceive
hues as being
be as having different categories
meaning
red is categorically different from
green and green categorically different
from red well if you have all of them
present what happens is that
we cannot help but see
a
see false edges where the transition
between one hue and another takes place
this doesn't take this doesn't happen in
a
gradient between two colors where you
have a smooth gradation
and and even more so
even more interestingly if you put put a
bright color like yellow and a
a darker color like blue on the same
spectrum well obviously the eye is going
to go straight for the yellows
loads a you can avoid this by making the
rainbow color map more isoluminant and
then of course your yellows turn to
brown
um
but really the most remarkable thing is
that
is that
these pallets tend to make details a lot
harder to see they create false details
while the real details are not nearly as
remarkable
well and that is because the human
visual system is is
is much better
to evolve to perceive small
discriminations in brightness than in
color nature sort of gave us color
vision as an afterthought
so let's let's look at another another
problem which
that takes place which is transparency
the overlay of of information layers and
and the normal way to implement
transparency is
you just blend them together using
linear interpolation
so that's an averaging operation it
reduces variation and
then you've got a little problem that
you can see right here where the
edges
where there is no overlay are more vivid
than the interior so
so if you just implement transparency in
the obvious way you can get reduced
contrast dull colors detail loss and a
lack of selective emphasis and i noticed
this problem
and i decided to get a phd from
cambridge for trying to solve it
um and i invented image blending
operators that are designed to produce
composite images that preserve
the key visual characteristics of their
components
there's like color contrast detail and
salience and this really illustrates
just how less vivid
any sort of standard
uh
their
transparency effect is compared to
natural photographs of course
that's because you need to use the red
operator so we can put the contrast back
in we can emphasize vivid colors bring
out the detail and then there's a really
neat method called salience preserving
compositing which takes each each
component image
predicts which region of the image is
most likely to attract the eye and then
preserves that
that re preserves the appearance of that
region while creating this seamless
less composition
and
and but of course you know
in the in the real world you just hack
it right
hell yeah
so here is a
here's how the world looks according to
facebook so
and to make this graph was a very it's a
beautiful trick really
you take take the arcs right the
friendship connections and you take them
them them in
in in order of decreasing length and
then you you color them according to a
suitable gradient with with the longest
ones being dark and then they turn blue
and finally the short ones
are white and
a map of the world emerges really cute
so i'll just very quick quickly say one
other thing this is a pro
project
that i worked on in
news visualization where
where we wanted to
visualize how our
online news evolves
evolves over time and we sort of start i
start out with talking to customers
doing focus groups and we finally we
decided to address like the basic
questions people have in public
relations
what what do i say who do i say it to
and did it make any difference now we i
i designed sort of objective metrics to
try to address these questions and this
is like the first
first or second prototype i came out
with and it's like a swiss army knife
like many exploratory data tools are
meaning you you can do
you can do everything but that's not
what the end user wants to do so i
needed to simplify this and and so i
went went from that to the idea of a
news radar which is this notion that
familiar visual metaphors make
interpretation easier so let's put
together a
speed gauge which and and and the radar
and this is
what i got
and
i i don't have the time to go for it in
detail see me afterwards if you're
you're interested but the idea was very
was just very simple is that we
for each news article you
you can
see how many
similar articles were published before
and how many similar were published
afterwards so you can compare the number
of precedents to the number of
consequences and the influence of a news
article may be
defined
as
the
number of consequences minus the number
of precedents and that's what we put
along the arc and then the radius is
simply the amount of attention it got
which is
the number of precedents plus the number
of consequences and the little dots are
each news article and then we can sort
of take a median and that is the
effectiveness of a news organization so
i'll go
very quickly for a few more examples
this is a brilliant
technique when you need to make sense
out of point clouds
allows you it's called spheres of
influence you put a
sphere
at the center of each point
with its radius equal to the nearest
neighbor distance and then you connect
every pair of points with
whenever those spheres of of influence
intersect and you can make that work in
any dimension with any
distance metrics for which you can
readily calculate
late uh neighborhood intersection and
the amazing thing is that it kind of
makes the same pattern as human
perception would what it lets you do is
to have a principled way of turning a
point cloud into a graph
now
since we're
now graphs are fantastically useful one
of the more more amazing you
more amazing practical uses is that
they're great for being able to
visualize hierarchical data structures
like xml json or html i've i've just got
thrown at me a few gigabytes of json
data and i want to be able to see at a
glance whether each
json record has similar or dissimilar
structure and right now i've got a huge
scrolling tree view if i had a gallery
of graphs i could actually see what's
going on
now i am going to go and go
um
really
okay i'll i'll go for this very quickly
this is a beautiful application in text
visualization where what we want to do
is make more meaningful word clouds and
the way we do this is by taking the text
and writing it
around
around the arc
and then placing each each word at its
average location in the text so
when you click on it right away you see
see whether it is present throughout the
text or only in a certain
region
and of course you can
do how you order the com
the elements meant of the text that it
comes from is up to you for example this
is done in reading order but you could
use i don't know sentiment or or some
other criteria
of course you can turn word clouds into
landscape wonderful
uh
technique called self-organizing maps
uh and the and one
and and another another interesting
issue is that we are often dealing with
grass and grass which are
quite difficult and
on because so many nodes are connected
in so many different ways this is a
lovely system from
health imagination and the first thing
to notice is that grass are best at
interaction so it is only when you hover
over a node that its connections are
emphasized and that means
that we can plot it in a far better way
so i know this this screen isn't great
but basically these are various medical
symptoms that go around
the circle
call and by distributing your nodes on a
circle you can plot the connections in a
very clear way and there's a wonderful
technique called hierarchical edge
bundles that can help you do it
so finally what's the secret to great
information visualization
well
this is what i know
start with the user not the data and not
the graph and ask some good questions
what will this allow you to do that you
can't do now
what difference can you observe in your
business
what value do you expect that this will
add to your business what will this let
your customers
do that they can't do now
what difference can your customers
observe in their business what value can
your customers expect that this will add
how does this fit with your your
strategic plans
how will you know that this has been a
success
how will you build on success and then
when you have a damn damn good answer
and you've slept
oh i like sleep
when you slept one night
and another on it
ask yourself the real question
so what
now
well
i'd like to just leave you with a little
point for discussion and i know i'm
almost through which is what is the
future of information
visualization
will charts become more interactive will
graphic designers get better at adding
subtle animation what impact will
augmented reality glasses have in making
information
visualization in everyday part of our
lives will cheap this place make ambient
visualizations ubiquitous will virtual
reality and gestures
extra interfaces change how we interact
with data
my name is mark grundland these
questions passionately fascinate me i'm
right now looking for something
interesting to do and if any of you have
a data set or a business problem or just
a fascinating challenge i could help you
with do let me know thank you
you pointed the way that
multiple displays of the same
information can aid understanding and
you also touched on interactivity as
being a useful tool
in your experience so far
which one of those do you prefer or you
prefer them both together
interaction
simple
graph
where you can poke the data
is what gets people thinking
if you
display
a dozen it doesn't grasp each one with a
different
perspective
wow that really makes them think
but is liable
more often than not to leave them
confused